rental home prices are just soaring
across the valley eight news now has
been getting calls we've been getting a
lot of emails from many of our viewers
about this issue christian casada spoke
to one resident about her situation and
you also have some tips christian if
people are out there looking for a new
place to live that's right deniseville
rental prices are going up by hundreds
and that is forcing many people to move
now if you're looking you know that
competition is fierce one resident tells
me she had to leave retirement just to
keep her home
i paid my rent on time all through the
pandemic i was never late marianne
cook's rent is going up and the increase
will set her back almost 200 a month
especially if you're on fixed income
like i said i
was not one of the people who got to
collect unemployment for all those
months because i'm retired and so
actually what's happened is i've had to
go out and get a part-time job at 67
years old john mcclelland is with
coldwell banker premier he says the
pandemic and the migration from
neighboring states is what's fueling the
rise in rental prices so supply and
demand on the demand side we've seen a
lot of
movement to the area
and
on the supply side we've seen that
construction deliveries have been
tempered by
issues with the pandemic if you're
looking for a new home standing out
among other applicants he says is key
set aside time to prepare have the money
and the references ready and add a cover
letter to polish your case resolving any
issues that you've had in your rental
history upfront
can can help and a lot of people they
know what those are but they
kind of let them
sit in the background until all of a
sudden becomes important remote working
and growing millennial families are also
pushing residents to move mclaren says
inventory and prices should scale back
around the holidays but at 67 i
shouldn't have to have a job
all right well another recommendation if
you are looking for a rental unit
according to mclean is talking to an
agent remember they can help you find
something that specifically fits your
needs christian gossip is 8 news now